bringing lara trump on this because she
knew one of the themes throughout her
the administration her father-in-law was
a part of and that she was uh
definitely part of those re-election
efforts was about the border
it doesn't take every single time you
bring up
a problem with the border from maoris to
the present united states they say
this is a problem they inherited do you
think that's true
oh it's it's patently false it's
ridiculous to
ever suggest that in fact i say it time
and time again
they were actually given a gift with the
southern border donald trump had set it
up
so well for them that all they had to do
was sit back
and do nothing not touch a thing keep
the policies in place that the trump
administration
had put there continue and finish
building the wall
and we would not see that we have over a
million migrants
that we know of guys that have come over
our border
illegally month after month we see that
rise and there is one reason for it it
is because
joe biden kamala harris campaigned on
the idea
that we were going to have an open
border if they were elected all of these
people heard that and they continue to
come over our southern border
what a ridiculous cop-out by the biden
administration to ever suggest such a
thing
now why do you think they want an open
border
well i think you uh you have a lot of
different scenarios there i mean maybe
the reason is that
they know that they are failing the
american people in many ways they know
they're going to have a really too
hard time in 22 in the midterm elections
they know they're going to have a really
tough
24 possible re-election if they both
decide to go for it
maybe they think that they bring
migrants over the southern border and
i don't know we don't have any voter id
like they want they wanted to federalize
the elections with hr1
fortunately that didn't go through um
you know there there are a lot of
questions as to why they would want to
do this but to a lot of people
it's very suspicious that this is their
way to win
elections in the future because if we
had a free and fair election
and every legal citizen got to vote i
think a lot of people are very
disappointed with the policies of the
democrat party
joe biden and kamala harris and it'll be
very hard for them to win elections
laura i don't know if you were watching
earlier in the program but we told about
this story
a couple of whistleblowers have come
forward they had been volunteering at
the child
migrant facility in fort bliss down in
texas
and as it turns out the bite
administration was telling
everybody it was working there hey we
got to downplay the situation
turned out it was a super spreader event
but they felt like
well if that gets out it's going to be
bad for all of us
because then we're going to have bad
publicity
and so now you know it's laid bare
they were trying to keep what was going
on with the children at that facility a
secret and they did
until the whistleblowers came forward
laura
yeah well and this is par for the course
um you know for this administration
remember in the very beginning
when we saw we got those those pictures
and videos
finally of the overcrowded facilities
they didn't want the press there
they didn't want the media there they
tried to keep everybody out they have
tried
to downplay this every step of the way
but i want to say kudos
to governor abbott for time finally
taking control
of this situation if we cannot rely on
the federal government
to protect our national security to
secure
our southern border it will come down to
the states having to do it and that is
exactly what you've seen happen
with governor greg abbott i mean it is
it's a preposterous that we found
ourselves
in this place but it is this
administration the biden administration
that continues to care more about people
who don't even live in america
than they do about american citizens all
right
thank you laura there's only there's a
lot of limits to what abbott can do but
um you're right he's trying